[Music]
the people responsible for the upcoming
Planet of the Apes four remained quiet
for a long time and in the meantime
there was even the impression that the
movie could be put on hold now after the
news about the allegedly very impressive
script a few weeks ago the production
seems to be finally moving forward again
not only did 20th century Studios
announced the official title Kingdom of
the Planet of the Apes they also
released a first image in a short
description of the cast the film marks
the beginning of a new saga that takes
place a few years after War for the
Planet of the Apes in the image you can
see an ape riding a horse in a
post-apocalyptic World nature seems to
have fought its way back as it covers
the gigantic skyscrapers and causes
waterfalls to form where there used to
be roads at first glance the scenery
even reminds us a little of the last of
us where the series of the same name is
supposed to be released in the near
future on the acting team the two young
Stars Owen Teague and Freya Allen have
been cast while Teague is known from it
and this year's horror film gone in the
night 21 year old Alan has become famous
as geralt's adopted daughter Siri in The
Witcher series it is being speculated
that Teague will take on the role of
Caesar's son Cornelius while Freya Allen
could play a human part probably that of
the adult Nova anticipation is high
after Insider's claim to have discovered
that the screenplay is expected to be a
very pleasant surprise we are looking
forward to the film which will be
directed by West ball an exact release
date has not been set yet but the movie
is expected to hit theaters in 2024.
foreign